For your standard, her testimony is your
evidence. You even made her nearly
commit suicide. Here are text messages
from his ex-wife that she's claimed she
tried to take her own life. Guys, I
still want what's best for you. I always
will. Oh, wow. S. You feel like you're
using a calm tone in your videos, etc.
It makes you look horrible, etc. And
now, what do you say? Look, she said,
you say, I always um I want good for
you. She goes, no you don't. I almost
killed myself and guess what? You didn't
care.
Islam is raising funds to establish a
masjid and community center in Norway
and they urgently need your support.
This donation will be a for you because
every person that comes a step closer to
Allah through your donation, you will
inshallah be reaping the reward. Click
the link and donate what you
can. Brothers and sisters and dear
friends, hope you guys will win in. So
this video is the last video that I'll
be doing on this matter cuz I've got
better things to focus on. But I just
thought, you know, sometimes in life you
have to return a favor. Now what do I
mean by that? Nothing was per say done
towards myself but this matter is beyond
myself or Muhammad or Salman or anyone
for that matter. This is something um
the um irresponsible behavior um this
attitude where Salman is someone that's
not qualified. Somebody who is so
obsessed over that he's made his whole
duny and I've said this before he's
obsessed with her. Yes. His whole dunya
has become his ex-wife dunya. Yeah. and
he he uh reminds me of someone who's
just got this obsessive behavior. So
what I'm going to do is uh I'm going to
return this favor to him and I'll be
very honest with you and Allahh is my
witness nobody has ever nobody has asked
me to do this video. Yes, nobody. For
those who are commenting saying oh
Muhammad if Muhammad hijab asked me to
do this video I'm doing this video
myself and my own initiative. Why?
Because the damage that he caused well I
wouldn't say the damage he caused. Well,
he tried to of course with the enemies
of Islam using this and his
irresponsible behavior. What we're going
to do today, brother and sisters, is
we're going to use Salman's words for
word against him. He said this
individual, the sister Bush, not Toba,
not Sara, not Aisha. For some reason,
she calls Aisha and Muhammad. Okay,
bizarrely. I wonder who told her that.
No, what I'm going to do is he said,
well, we said, what is the evidence?
Where is the evidence? Because the if
the bar is so low then we're going to
everybody's doomed. Everybody can be
accused left and center. Allah says in
in the
Quran bring your evidences if you are
truthful. But what we're going to do
today is this guys we're going to put
the shar aside and show you how much how
damaging it is when we flip everything
on its head towards Salman because
Salman said
Bushra's statements her testimony is her
evidence. No problem. Let's go with it
Salman. No problem. We have the Sharia
and we have Salman. We're going to go
with Salman's worldview. We're going to
go with Salman's conditions. No problem.
Her testimony is her evidence. I accept
for the argument sake. I'm going to
accept. And what we're going to do now
is we're going to dive deep into your
ex-wife. How? We're going to go and look
at her testimonies against you, Salman.
We're going to look at them now. We're
going to hear them one by one. The
abuse, how you used to beat her. That's
what she said. By the way, look, if you
say come and see me, Ali, you are lying,
brother. I'm not lying. Her testimony is
her evidence. Like you said, her
claiming that your sister tried to run
her over. Your sister before you come
and say to me, Ali, you're lying again,
brother. Her testimony is her evidence.
Her claiming, and again, I seek refuge
in Allah from accusing anybody of this,
that you committed z. And there's a
video. Again, I'm I'm not saying you
did. I'm just saying her testimony is
her evidence. That's all I'm saying. I'm
not I'm making this clear on video,
guys. I am in no way, shape, or form
saying Salman done
this. I'm just saying her testimony is
her evidence. That's all I'm saying in
Okay. So, we're going to hear these
recordings one by one. And if we apply
the standard of Salman who's an
unqualified person who has no Islamic
credentials, who is somebody who is
obsessively obsessed, he's made his
whole dunya, his ex-wife dunya. When
somebody like that who is raging in
anger like how Busha was going to the
levels of making dua against his
children's cells and this and that and
working with Shayan and working with the
most violent and the wild and trying to
give information to the enemies of Islam
and you name it, etc., etc., etc. Here
are the clips. And we want to apply the
same thing to someone. I just want the
whole world to just hear out Dunya, the
ex-wife of Salman. Let's hear her out.
Let's hear what she had to say. Because
you know why? One year ago, I made a
video defending Salman because there was
a lot of women, not just Dunya. Yes.
Many women who oppressed their husbands,
by the way. Yes. Okay. I hope sisters
can talk a bit more about this. You
know, our feminist sisters. Please talk
more about this these vile evil satanic
women who are stopping their ex-husbands
from seeing the children. These vile
individuals who are stopping their
children and this is a major sin. Talk
about those sisters please. If you can
raise awareness towards that we really
appreciate that as well. Yeah. How they
are ending their marriages on baseless
claims and oppressing the husbands.
Let's talk a bit about this as well.
Let's talk about these radical feminists
who are oppressing their husbands. Let's
raise awareness of that. But anyways,
we'll come to that later. Here is the
first clip. Let's watch it for myself.
Zia is concerned due to the fact San has
been showing up at her venues and
causing
disturbances. This is another egregious
lie. As I never showed up to any of her
venues or caused any disturbances as
with the growing list of lies, this is
another claim rooted in lies which she
cannot provide any evidence for nor
furnish any witnesses. Bring forth your
proofs of adultery in our marriage.
After all, you told your friend Nahila
that I was caught on camera. Go ahead,
release it to the public. Bring forth
your proofs of physical violence in our
marriage. Bring forth your proofs of
your ex-sister-in-law trying to run you
over in the parking lot on three
different occasions. Bring forth your
proofs. And if you cannot, by Allah, may
you always be known as a wicked and
vicious liar amongst the people on this
earth and amongst the angels. until you
repent and until you issue a public
apology to myself, to my wife, to my
family, and to all the people you have
slandered and harmed. I challenge the
leaders of our community to prove that
they aren't just puppets filled with
words and lacking any form of action. I
challenge them to help assemble a group
of three to five leaders that are
impartial that know neither myself nor
Dunya and that we sit down me and my
wife Dun and her brother or her father
and we present our proofs and evidences
and whomver is found to be an error or
lying or slandering that they are
compelled to issue a public apology. I
mean I don't know why Salman's so worked
up about it. He himself knows and he
knows that dunya. So if dunya came to me
and said salman has had zena in our
marriage. There are video recordings his
um sister tried to run me over. He used
to beat me. I put a restraining order on
him and we're going to listen that now
as well. Duna claiming uh she goes back
to the police and reports how he's
harassing her. I mean I could have take
that and go public. Can you imagine me
doing exactly what Salman done and said
yeah your word is your testimony. I mean
your testimony is a is um is your
evidence. Halas son man would you not
come and say what a reckless man you
are. Alli you did not hear my sight or
even if I reach out to you and you said
this I said no no problem brother no
problem I'm still going to make this
public I'm going to go public. You would
call me a reckless man wouldn't you? You
would say Alli why would you take her
word Salman that's exactly what you did
though bro now let look look now but we
are making you taste your own medicine
bro. We are making you taste your own
medicine. That's number one. So look
again guys, you heard it clearly. Duna,
his ex-wife is claiming that. And again,
this is a this is a big allegation.
There has to be evidences. Yeah. Salman,
there have to be evidences. Okay. But
I'm just bringing this to the public. I
just want the public to know. Let's
listen to the next one. You mean this
happened at Roots and she tried to run
you over at Roots? She said all that
stuff to you at Roots and she tried to
run you
over. Like do do you know do I'm trying
to comprehend it in my mind when I was
thinking about that. Do you know the
weight of that? That's literally that
somebody has tried physically harming
you and or killing you. And guess what?
The way I have proof too. One of the
girls that was with me spoke to Kamatti
without telling me.
Okay. Without telling me. She told me
today. She actually sent me a text
message in the morning. Mhm.
And she asked me if Mui come spoke to
me. I was like, "Why?" She said,
"Cuz I was at school." She told me, she
said, "I spoke to Miy cuz I was worried
about your
You was worried about what?" I was like,
"What did you tell him?" She said she
was worried about my safety.
I was like, "What do you mean?" Mhm.
She said, "I spoke to
him and I think you should talk to him
too about what happened."
But she
said that if I do a police
report that she'll get stuck.
Okay. So, why not do that? And forever
if if she tried running you over in the
parking lot, why not? And then guess
what? What?
We called a non-emergency line. They
said that if I file it, she will never
be able to go anywhere where I am. So if
I'm at the mid, she comes, all I have to
do is call the police and they will
arrest her. Okay. So why not do that?
Cuz I wanted to ask M is that okay? Cuz
that will
mean that I would be depriving someone
of going some [__]
And so if he says that that's fine
and yeah, I'm going to do it. There you
go. That's the second one where she's
claiming she's crying. This a woman look
I mean we need to believe you know you
know she's crying. She's emotional you
know and Salman are you trying is your
are you sending your sister-in-law to
run over your exes? What's going on
Salman? I mean what's going on here? Are
you trying to send people again? Again,
this what we're saying is her uh
testimony is her evidence. She's
testified. That's her evidence. So guys,
she's brought evidence according to
Salman standards. She has evidence.
She's crying. She's said this to sister,
you know, it's not someone far. You
can't make this stuff up, you know. So
it's an evidence. Let's go to the next
video. Inshallah. I'm a lecturer and I
was here giving a lecture on domestic
violence and my ex-husband came um and
started screaming and yelling and put
putting up a storm while I was speaking.
Uh he had to be escorted out. However,
I'd like to document this because I do h
I did have an emergency temporary
restraining order. However, that one um
expired and I want to just make sure I
document everything so that I can get a
a permanent
one. Okay. Wonderful. I just want to
know when to go outside cuz actually
afraid to go outside. Someone actually
went and got my car and I've just been
inside because I was afraid to leave. Um
because he sometimes follows me. He
followed me to dinner one night. Um I
was sitting and having dinner with my
brother and he pulled up a chair and sat
and made a scene. I did call the police
but they said that he left and it was
too late. Um and this happened in
Richardson. So I'm just a little
worried. So, I just don't want to go
outside and find him there. So, I'm just
wanting to not go outside until the
police is actually there because I'm
afraid. Okay. Um, what I'll do is I'll
um the officer will either give you a
call or he'll have us give you a call or
he'll just go in. Perfect. Okay.
Perfect. I think a call is better
because it's a big building. It's a
church. It used to be a church so it has
multiple like rooms and stuff and I'm
upstairs. So, I'm just going to I'm
waiting it out. The organizers thought
it would be most safe if they took me
upstairs and waited. So, we waited.
We're just waiting it out. Yeah. Now, in
this clip, she is going to the officer
to the restraining order ran out. She
went for I mean, what kind of abuse was
she going for? How fever she's of her
life that she's gone back to the police
to get another restraining order on you
because you are obsessively not leaving
her alone. So, on this video, brother
says, you can see, subhan Allah, that
she had the the first one that was
granted to her, which is restraining
order. Most likely the police saw some
kind of and evidence to grant that
restraining order and then that ran out
and they she goes and applies for
another one. So the question we're going
to ask is again we're using man it's not
the sharan because we can say this all
goes in the bin. Yeah. Okay. Um because
slander is a big thing you know is a big
thing. So according to this um uh subhan
Allah that that restraining order that
she put that means that you for your
standards her testimony is her evidence.
So look, you are now harassing her.
Okay. Not only that, you even well again
her evidence, her testimony is evidence.
You even um made her nearly commit
suicide. Here are text messages of
brothers and sisters, text messages from
his ex-wife showing that in multiple
occasions that she's claimed she tried
to take her own life. Guys, look, I want
to read it for yourself. Look guys, this
is it says this is the Salman thing. But
I still want what's best for you. I
always will. Oh well son man you don't
you feel like you're using a calm tone
in your videos etc. It makes you look
honorable etc. Look my friend your
credibility is in the bin now after this
whole situation that you done your
credibility in the bin after you accuse
Omar of free mixing and flirting with
your wife. Okay your credibility is gone
and now what did you say? Look she said
you say I always um I want good for you.
She goes no you don't. I almost killed
myself and guess what? You didn't care.
So subhan Allah. Basically, she's
attempted something in front of you or
whatever it is for that matter and she's
saying you did not care. Again, I'm not
saying this is true or not. I'm just
saying her testimony is her evidence,
Salman. In another message, she says,
"That's that's it. I'm done arguing. I'm
just going to kill my effing self and
end this whatever." She says, "Okay,
again, what are you doing to her? What
some man what have you been doing to
her?" Subhan Allah. that a woman is
going down the route of taking her own
life which is haram which is a major
sin. Major sin. Yes. Some people say you
can't do janaz over this person. Yes.
Okay. You're bringing to this level.
Yes. And again I'm not saying this is
true or not. I'm just saying her
testimony is your evidence. Yeah. Sal
what what have you been doing? Another
message here. She goes wall I'm going to
kill myself. She goes wall I'm going to
kill myself. And you say what? Please
stop. Take a step back please.
Okay. What's going on? Salman. What have
you been doing to dun? Huh? Again, look,
we're not saying it's true or not. We're
just saying her testimony is her
evidence. And I think you guys get the
point, guys. You get the point. If I was
to go publicly, if Dunya Duna came to me
and I tried to speak to Salman and
Salman said, "This is not true." And I
said, "No, no, no, brother. No, no, no.
I'm going to be the hero. I've heard
her. I'm going to be the champion." Yes.
Okay. You know, brother, let me tell you
something. Yeah. Okay. Let me tell you
something. We're going to go to some
Quran inshallah. And let me tell you
something. Number one, an open facet
should be warned against somebody where
multiple women who are coming. Let me
tell you something. Yes. In my lifetime
in the da there's been individuals where
multiple people have come towards us.
Multiple woman. And what we've done is
and and it's not something major by the
way. It wasn't something major of no no.
It was an irresponsible behavior of um
this position. Yes. And what happened is
we freed
ourself. And guess what? We didn't go
out and make a public scene and this
that you know why? Because number one
this man was doing some things which you
should not be doing. Yes. And we just
said you know what this happened too
many times. Too many people are coming
and we freed ourself. We didn't want to
come and and we you know informed we
need to inform etc. Yes. Now we're
talking about brothers and sisters
here an open fast. Do you know Muhammed
Jab to be an open evildoer? Have you
seen him? I mean, you might agree with a
lot of things he does. No problem. Yes,
there's things hijab doesn't agree. I
do, and I don't agree with stuff he
does. But to come and take this to
another level of a public humiliation or
an accusation of a woman who's not
mentally stable, making dua against
children's cells, working with the
enemies of Islam, seeing children's
hands, shake, shake hands with Shayan,
and then a audio recording of her father
comes out. In the audio even there is
like we can't know who it is. And again,
who is this person? We don't know. after
I got duped into it by Bushra and the
story she didn't tell me in full and
she's claiming now this is her father
and not only that the audio recording
within itself if it is true it's her
father she's clearly gone against her
father her father was saying do not
marry if this is if this is true by the
way this makes your situation look worse
your client is being told apparently yes
by this father that don't go ahead don't
go ahead and she goes ahead oh how's she
going ahead without a father do you see
my point subhan allah and there is
verses in the Quran which we're going to
read and we're going to give you a clear
of ma and these are sahab
hazal told ma that he committed a major
sin which is zena and
hazal told him to go to the prophetam
and tell him what he done and he came to
the prophetam in a long hadith and
multiple times told the prophetam that
he committed zena the prophetam turned
away from him not once not twice not
three times four times bro four times
and this is a direct confession of a
major is sin. My friend, one woman came
to you that you don't know who she is.
You can't even verify. You jumped at the
opportunity, man. Following the sunnah
prophetic tradition is what a man sahaba
comes with a major sin. The prophet
lives away four times. Nope, you didn't.
You didn't know. She said and he said,
"Maybe you making a good assumption.
Maybe you've kissed her." Kissed her.
Maybe. Yes. Says, "No, I've committed
zero." The prophet was avoiding it. Not
only that, the prophet even asked if his
psychological wellbeing is intact.
Subhan Allah. To a person who committed
a major sin who's coming out publicly,
the prophetam is ignoring him to avoid a
capital punishment. You, my friend, are
an opportunistic person under the
disguise of trying to be honorable and
I'm here for the sisters. You're a liar.
Yes. Actually, I'm not going to say
that. The person the believer is
anything but a liar. You've got issues.
You've got some kind of issues. Okay.
I'm not going to say you're a liar. Yes.
What I'm saying is this. you at first
opportunity when you hear it you're like
yes Muhammad hijab this going to get
good views yes this is what you done
because and after that the prophet even
had a go hazal and told him you could
have ask him to repent look at the
prophetam's sunnah and how he carried
himself and look at what kind of an
irresponsible man you are her testimony
is the evidence backfiring on you with
your ex uh with your ex-wife and there's
eyes in the Quran look let's read it for
ourel yeah here is it permissible
to pray against
someone more than they deserve like the
look in Islamic law. It is not
permissible to transgress in
supplication dua even against someone
who wronged you. You're allowed to pray
against someone in proportion to the
injustice but shouldn't go beyond that
beyond that and wish upon them more than
they did to you. She was not even making
dua against Muhammad hijab saying let
his blood be frozen. This is the dua
made against the kufur. Yes. Not only
that, she was making dua against the
children's cells. Does this go? She was
saying cancer. Yes. Does this show you
that this woman is psychologically well
and you want her to do? You want her to
bring her daughter and hijab bring his
children and they curse each other. Are
you are you son? I'm starting to
question your psychological wellbeing.
Not mushers now. Yes. Number two, Allah
says in the Quran here, but the evil
plot does not encompass except its own
people. Okay. This implies that Allah is
just and repays each person according to
their deeds. Also, Allah says in the
Quran, Allah does not like the public
mention of evil except by the one who
has been wronged. Okay? If this was like
multiple women, three, four, five, six,
seven, they will come and say, well done
a second, what's going to all these
women have come and plotted together. We
will say that you are an opportunistic
man who came and looked for any
opportunity because of Muhammad Hijab's
name to take him down. You did the same
with Omar. Your credibility is in the
bin Sal man. Yes. and your calm tone of
you know talking in a calm tone we don't
buy it people have seen it with my video
that I done alhamdulillah people realize
what kind of a reckless man you are
working with an enemy of Islam who went
to the enemies of Islam who backstabbed
her afterwards and I will end on this
note the prophetam wanted to conceal the
major sin of a companion that has done a
major sin this is the prophetic
tradition not a fazik not someone who's
openly committing evil you did what took
advantage took an opportunity unity to
attack Muhammad hijab. And the question
is why? You didn't only take advantage
of this whole situation, but you also
took advantage of Bushra. When she came
to me, I heard her story. I recorded it,
but I had the decency to go and speak to
the other side eventually and hear it
and I thought to myself, if this woman
is saying this and doing this and going
to this level, there is to me the sanity
is in question. So, I will be
irresponsible to go out there. I don't
care if hijab is someone I know, I don't
know to do this, but you've done it. So,
alhamdulillah, I am happy that the whole
world is now seeing what kind of a
reckless man you are and what kind of a
individual who casually and easily um
slammed people Omar uh your ex Muhammad
hijab now on the list. So subhan Allah,
I thank Allahh that he brought this to
light that the whole world has now seen
Manuel who you were not qualified and
you with your standards that we used
against you her testimony as a witness
backfires on you because your ex-wife
Duna has claimed you hitting her um
harassing her about Zena again um you
nearly caused her to take her own life.
Subhan Allah. Again, in the Sharia, this
will be all thrown in the bin and
everything you said about hijab will be
thrown in the bin. But according to your
standards, you are in big trouble, my
friend. And I want the whole world to
know your side of your wife. And what
apparently you put her through, her
testimony is her witness. And I will
repeat again, in no way, shape or form
am I saying what Dunya is saying against
Salman is true. All I'm doing is
applying Salman's standards to his
ex-wife just like he did with hijab and
saying her testimony is her evidence and
hope that you taste your own medicine
inshallah. That's all I have to say
broshah. And I end this whole chapter
from here brothers and sisters. I don't
want to talk about this guy ever again.
Alhamdulillah. The matter is clear. My
job was to defend the honor of every
believer. And you guys know it's not
Muhammad. It's this about Islam and the
honor of a believer. And I've done this
with people all over the world. People
who know no being attacked unjustly. I
defend another sister being I travel to
France to a a a sister who killed
herself because of a false video going
about her honor and I do it
alhamdulillah according to what the
Sharia says not my desires and wants and
what I think it is true or not or some
sisters coming and crying and thinking
it's true brothers and sisters that's
all I have to say
inshallah prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said whoever builds a masid for
the sake of Allah subhanaa tala Allah
will build for him a similar house in
Jenna
On that day where Allah subhana t tells
us that our books will be given and
every little atom weight of good deed
you've done will be there and imagine
you see a mountain and you're like what
a lucky person which righteous person
and Allah says this is for you for me
yes what did I do you allowed people to
pray you built a masid I never had the
money to build a masjid oh Allah you
helped you gave towards it and Allah
gives you the reward of as if you've
built it donate now guys and do delay
and share the video for extra rewards.
[Music]